and welcome professor
uh hello welcome uh thank you okay and I
guess it's coming there yeah
so we're ready to get going and we're
live streaming on to LinkedIn and
YouTube
yeah and
uh here we go we've got the uh
program preview for the professional
certification program in blockchain
what we'll be talking about today with
Professor Sandeep Shukla and uh
Dr Shukla is the coordinator for the
national blockchain project
which is uh centered at IIT Concourse
um and
he is one of the
faculty leaders of the Institute
would you like to speak a little bit
more about yourself Dr Shukla
yeah so uh I am currently a professor of
computer science and engineering at IIT
kanpur and I used to be the head of the
department until 2020 and until
2015 I was a faculty for 14 years in the
U.S
and then I moved to India to IIT kanpur
and we I right now I am actually a
program director for a Technology
Innovation Hub here at IIT kanpur as
well as a coordinator for the uh cyber
security Center and also the coordinator
for the national blockchain project
uh and we have been uh working on uh
National blockchain project
to actually ensure that blockchain
technology is used by various government
entities in India
for various e-governance Solutions
and in the last two three years we have
been doing a lot of this for example we
have uh implemented a blockchain based
uh land registry system in the state of
Karnataka where Bangalore is and it has
been piloted in six districts already we
also have developed a e-procurement
solution on blockchain for the same
government
we have been working for the city of
kanpur for uh in property uh development
rights as tokens on a blockchain and
also uh we just started talking to the
UC government for land record registry
project on blockchain we also have
developed a self-governing identity
Solution on blockchain
and this particular blockchain solution
is being used uh can be used for various
types of credentials uh that one can
think of identity credentials or degree
credentials certificate credentials uh
taxpayer identification potential and so
on and so far it has been used by
multiple different institutes including
our IIT kanpur uh to provide degrees on
the blockchain to the students of IIT
Khan put in the last two years also we
have done that for uh IIT indoor we have
done that for nit rautela uh Indira
Gandhi National open University
and we also have done this for the
equity the the up governments technology
University
and so 100
more than 100 000 degrees have been
given on that blockchain
so so we have been doing a number of uh
other things but uh I guess that is
enough to say about myself
um thank you and we also have with us
Mayan tarari who is a product manager
here at simply learn simply learn is the
delivery partner for IIT com4
and um so the curriculum comes from IIT
and is overseen by Dr uh Shukla and then
we provide the platform on which it's
delivered
um so what we'll be talking about today
uh we'll be asking you a couple of
questions along the way yeah and uh and
to We'll be asking the audience as well
through some polls
um
we'll be talking of course about
blockchain as a technology as an
industry as an as a career opportunity
we'll cover what this program offers to
Learners and how it gets a learner's job
ready
and then we'll provide information about
how to enroll and we'll take questions
from the audience so if you have
questions for Dr Shukla please put them
into
a q a and we'll take them from there
okay so are you are you going to run the
slides or uh
yeah I've got the slide deck here it's
updated
okay so so I I guess this is this is a
um uh kind of uh evening uh well evening
at least in India uh where we would like
to talk to you about uh what is this
professional certification program in
blockchain that IIT kanpur is offering
with simply learn uh and it has been
almost two years now I believe uh that
we we have been offering this program
and uh this uh this evening will talk
about uh why you should enroll in this
professional certification program in
blockchain
so going forward
so I guess uh
these we need to move the uh
slides along uh which one are you seeing
doctor
I'm seeing the the first
um slide these uh the title slide oh the
title slide okay yeah
let me reshare my screen just to make
sure
yeah so as most of you since you are
attending this you probably have heard
what blockchain is and what uh what
blockchain is being used for one of the
of course common usage of blockchain
Technology came from cryptocurrency uh
Bitcoin uh ethereum Monero and uh Solana
and various other cryptocurrencies
however uh the technology that came out
of this development of this private
so-called private money in terms of
cryptocurrency
has already given us a number of
Technology Solutions that can be used
for other applications other than
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency is one
application of blockchain but blockchain
because we have this notion of smart
contracts uh and uh notion of immutable
uh decentralized Ledger and the idea of
privacy and idea of Integrity of data
and security and
the authentication uh therefore number
of different solutions has come up a lot
of solutions are related to uh
enforcing contracts across multiple
multiple different organizations
uh I guess the yeah and uh also supply
chain uh supply chain provenance
tracking and many other like as I
mentioned land record registry uh
identity uh there are various types of
credentials this kind of applications
have come up
uh so as per uh the market data it seems
that the compound annual growth rate of
blockchain Market is about uh is quite
remarkable 67.3 percent through uh the
year 2025
and also
the markets and markets predicts that
spending uh in in this technology will
jump to about 40 billion dollars in 2025
so basically what these numbers are not
important what is important is that this
is a growth sector of of a new
technology and it has gone through the
hype cycle and it is now at a point
where it is being deployed for various
kinds of solutions and therefore in the
next uh you know couple of years we'll
see a lot more growth and now we are at
the growth phase of the technology after
it has gone through high phases and and
various other phases
so so therefore uh we can uh we can
basically uh think of this as a good
technology uh that yeah one could gain
expertise in in order to actually have a
good career growth
okay so next slide
yeah so uh blockchain technology uh
actually requires quite a few different
uh Technologies uh to to be mastered
of course this is very much uh dependent
on cryptography and the notion of
cryptography is best uh Illustrated as
cryptocurrency
um cryptocurrency Solutions illustrate
how cryptography is very important in
blockchain
and Bitcoin is an example and Bitcoin is
actually the first blockchain that we
have seen and it has given us a very
good ideas about how to use Technologies
such as cryptography hashing algorithms
decentralized conferences uh this kind
of digital signatures this kind of ideas
together in a very clever technological
solutions and so Bitcoin is an important
component of learning in uh when we
learn blockchain we also see the dlts
the distributed Ledger technology which
is slightly different from standard
cryptocurrency blockchains uh
hyperledger would be an example of
distributed Ledger technology which is
actually is one form of blockchain
we also learn about ethereum as as it
grew from Bitcoin technology with the
ability to do smart contracts and
hyperledger also does Smart contracts
and also consensus mechanism is also
very important consensus is the way that
decentralized entities together make
decisions because we have to keep a
uniform view a consistent view of The
Ledger which is maintained across
multiple different entities who do not
necessarily trust each other so there
has to be a robust consensus algorithm
which is tolerant to at least a fraction
of
users such fraction of nodes not
behaving in a trustworthy Manner and
also networks and workflows and
transaction workflows Etc these are some
of the concepts that you have to learn
in in order to learn about
the blockchain technology next slide
please support for me also the slides
[Music]
would you like to like me to share
actually mine is not necessarily updated
so we have to do something about this
professional shared the updated
yeah for some reason uh the change that
Stuart is making is not reflecting here
but uh yeah my apologize for that I
apologize for that uh
link up here we're having terrible
storms where I am so if something
happened to my internet connection I
will rejoin
blood deck in progress
yeah apologies for that
so let me share my screen until then
oh but I am disabled from uh screen
sharing let me um you can go ahead and
do that now okay
yeah so can you see my screen now yes we
can
okay yeah so we were on this slide and I
was explaining what are the different
technology that we'll be learning in
this course
and uh the kind of skills that one could
actually uh uh think about uh uh you
know obviously you will be learning this
uh basic fundamentals of Technology you
will learn various applications uh and
our design applications but the kind of
job jobs that you might actually find
and after completing this kind of a
course is uh either as a blockchain
developer if you are very good in
programming uh but if you are also good
in front-end programming that is uh
doing the web design then you could also
possibly become a blockchain web
designer which is basically for
Designing the front end of the
blockchain application uh you can also
become a blockchain solution architect
if you can gain a very good
understanding of multiple different
types of blockchain
and what kind of applications with uh
what kind of blockchain Technology like
where uh a public blockchain fits where
a private blockchain fits where in uh
you know partition uh versus permission
less blockchain fits uh which ones
require you to have more privacy
preserving transactions if you can
somehow uh can gain that understanding
uh different people have gain different
types of understanding from completion
of a course like this because they have
different interests so blockchain
solution architect would be one of the
one of the good ones that to to try to
become of course you can become
blockchain project manager where you
manage projects that are based on
blockchain technology you can also
become uh on a in the user interface
user experience designer for blockchain
in applications when the application is
quite complex and and requires different
types of interaction between the users
and the sys backend system uh you can
become a blockchain quality engineer
where you will be testing the blockchain
based Solutions and and providing uh
quality uh guidance and then you may
also go into blockchain legal Consulting
of course if you have also a legal
background
so as as was said that the industry is
growing very fast in blockchain and so
are the salaries so from The Glassdoor
Source uh the simply learned has learned
that uh the salary range could be as
high as 10 lakhs per second uh sorry per
month not per second
to about uh three lakhs per second uh
sorry per month uh in case of uh in case
of uh on the lower end uh so this is the
kind of salary range there is a median
salary or average salary is about about
six lakhs uh or five and a half lakhs
and different companies are hiring
especially I know personally people from
Accenture Oracle
Microsoft uh they're hiring in
blockchain uh technology uh so
blockchain technology is a very
technology uh solution architect
production technology develop blockchain
application developer blockchain
front-end developer for a blockchain
project manager these are very very uh
very highly sought
skills uh in today's market
so so the question is uh here is a poll
question now if Stuart is back then we
can run the poll I don't know uh if I
can run the pool or Mayan can yeah so I
think the pool is uh is is now being run
so I'll give you a minute to actually
fill uh the uh uh one of the choices
or you can make multiple choices
actually
uh you can choose more than one uh
answer here
and I'll keep the poll running until I
see the numbers stop changing so right
so
um you know this is just for us to
understand uh you know where you are in
terms of uh are you trying to find a
good uh good curriculum or are you
trying to uh get something that has
practical exposure or are you there are
lots of videos online so uh but you
might find it difficult to learn from uh
existing pre-recorded videos and you
want live interaction classes
or it is because your schedule is uh too
uh you know busy to uh actually
um get into a program
so this is the what we are asking you to
uh put in okay and uh please get your
answers in we'll close the poll in 10
seconds
the most common answer among the
audience about half of you said that it
uh you're worried that you wouldn't get
practical exposure that you can show off
your skills with
um plus behind that people who
haven't found a program with a
comprehensive curriculum yet or have
difficulty fitting this into a work
schedule into their existing work
schedule
you're right we can go on okay so so
yeah so we get some understanding of
where you are so uh now let's talk about
this program
now this program is actually
um built for uh the kind of problems
that you are talking about
so it's a four month duration it
requires you to commit about five to ten
hours per week uh you know this is uh
something that you uh need to commit to
actually learn something that is very
useful practical and also a
comprehensive
so the curriculum has been designed by
us at IIT kanpur uh it's a comprehensive
curriculum uh with an industry aligned
learning path the labs and Hands-On
projects are there for practical
experience which are labs are integrated
to the learning material
uh we have online live virtual
classrooms
uh with uh peer and instructor
interaction
uh and that's what is uh going to be
helpful for those who cannot learn from
uh pre-recorded lectures
and it's uh supposed to be it's designed
to be flexible to fit your lifestyle and
schedule
so and at the end of it all you get a
blockchain certification by IIT kanpur
it's uh provided by the IIT kanpur
Center for continuing education
and uh the blockchain uh it's a 70 plus
hours of Applied online learning with
industry experts uh four plus Hands-On
projects in integrated Labs plus there
will be a Capstone project and we'll say
a little bit more about the Capstone
project
and then every month there is a master
class from IIT kanpur which I believe is
uh very uh interesting for you to attend
but it's not a mandatory for getting
your certificate
so why why is it good uh why we think
it's a it's a good for your resume
because uh it has IIT kanpur name behind
it so uh it's a home to the IIT kanpur
as you know is the home to the National
blockchain project
and we provide this program provides you
with master class with IIT kanpur
faculty uh Capstone project to Showcase
your skills and the certificate is from
IIT kanpur and having IIT kanpur on your
CV might be a good accomplishment for
for many of you some of you might
already be from iits so but for many
people it might be actually a good thing
now coming to the uh eligibility and
prerequisites so you have to have some
basic understanding of mathematics and
basic understanding of programming if
possible in Java
uh the mathematics is required not
necessarily uh you know High you know
High skill mathematics but basic
Mathematics Algebra Etc because we are
talking going to talk about cryptography
and digital signatures uh hashes and
things like that which require you to
understand some basic maths about
functions and and random numbers and and
uh things like that so therefore you
have to have some mathematics uh
understanding and some programming
background especially if it is in Java
that's that's that's very good
uh you have to have a bachelor's degree
uh with 50 marks or higher
and uh also you have to uh you know we
do not require you to have a work
experience before you take this course
but many of our Learners are actually
working professionals and many have very
many years of experience
so there is another poll that Stuart
will run now which is uh how many years
of experience do you currently have just
to get an understanding of your the
makeup of the audience
and the answers are coming in fast so we
won't keep this open for too much longer
but about another 15 seconds or so
and the winner is
ah so so we have uh 51 currently
studying whereas 31 percent is more than
five years
that's a
bimodal distribution
yeah yeah
okay so uh so uh that you know if you
have more years of experience it helps
even though it's not required because
you have had the work experience of the
time management experience and so on uh
but anyway so you can actually do this
course uh before you start your work
experience if you if that is what you
would like
now how this program prepares you so uh
so we have a learning management system
uh which manages your curriculum so you
have a access to a portal through which
your curriculum is managed your your
learning material Etc uh your live
virtual classroom Etc accessible
uh you have labs and projects uh that
that will allow you to actually do
Hands-On uh experience get a hands-on
experience uh you have we have tests and
assessments that will test your skills
so you actually are are studying uh the
material covered and then Capstone
project is one of the major
um thing uh in the in the curriculum uh
in which you do some really practical
blockchain application and there is a
progress tracking uh through which
eventually you will get your certificate
and then we have several support tools
on the Learning Management platform
and uh the program uh is uh built step
by step so we get initially uh
orientation followed by uh basic
concepts fundamental concepts of
blockchain and then an exposition to the
how the Bitcoin technology works
then once you learn Bitcoin you want to
see how you can actually extend the
capabilities of transactions uh through
programming and that's where you go into
ethereum and smart contracts
and then you understand the notion of
consensus and consensus algorithms and
then you go into distributed Ledger
technology especially uh particular
focus on hyperledger fabric
and then you will you learn how to
develop smart contracts and networks and
then we also talk about certain other
blockchain platforms like quota and Iota
Etc so to access to give you a uh so
that you don't get stuck with any idea
that hyperledger is the only way to
solve a blockchain application or
ethereum is the only way to solve a
blockchain application then we learn
more about applications and then we do
the Capstone project once you finish
your Capstone project
you get your certificate and uh there is
an elective every month that is
a an evening on a weekday we actually
have an IIT concur faculty come and talk
about
Topics in blockchain technology and
applications
so usually I do that but sometimes uh my
colleagues also do that
so the kind of uh libraries and tools
that are that are that you use in this
course uh of course you understand about
Bitcoin you can basically start uh
creating a Bitcoin wallet and and
observe uh even if you don't participate
in Bitcoin uh purchasing or for other
activities uh ethereum also you learn
how to uh use ethereum mainnet as well
as test Nets uh you learn to write
solidity programs which are basically
for smart contracts then you go and
learn hyperledger and specific in
particular hypo laser fabric and then
you learn also a truffle which is a tool
for uh for developing smart contracts
which is uh basically a very good uh uh
ecosystem on which to actually
deploy and test your smart contracts on
a private ethereum Network and then
multi-chain is is a way to integrate
different blockchains different
blockchain platforms like you can have
ethereum and hyperledger working
together uh through multi change so
there are several uh technologies that
you learn in this course
so uh normally the projects that you
work on have real business implications
uh like you learn how to do smart
contract development how to deploy a
smart contract and how to test the smart
contract
uh you understand
hyperledger fabric uh say how to set it
up and how to write chain code which is
the Smart contract for hyperledger
you also learn about ethereum wallet and
how to install them and how to make
transactions and so on and you can do
this on test net so you don't have to
spend any money on the actual ethereum
or Bitcoin Network
now Capstone project is also other than
the fact that it allows you to use what
you learn in this course into a
comprehensive project but also it helps
you to actually put it into in your
resume because it's a it's a substantial
project therefore if your future
employer says that okay you have taken
this course but do you have any
practical experience and then you can
show your Capstone project as as
something and of course the caption
project how
um uh how uh elaborate and how much
technology focused the capsule project
is is up to you uh there are several
things to choose from and therefore uh
you better and more complex application
you develop better for you to Showcase
it in your portfolio for your future
employees
uh so we have multiple different domains
from which these problems are chosen uh
that you are going to solve in your
Capstone project it could be from
Financial domain it could be Healthcare
manufacturing or government service Etc
and uh usually they uh involve real
world business requirements and with
Hands-On learning and their rigorous in
nature and provide great examples of
work for your portfolio and resume and
your instructors will actually help
along uh to actually accomplish what you
want to accomplish here
so we have um uh different uh so uh so I
have this uh IIT kanpur has designed the
curriculum but it is delivered by very
experienced industry uh developers of
blockchain uh technology so here are
some of them but I I believe that now
there are more I don't have don't have
the latest Flight Deck so I am unable to
show you the uh the address late of uh
uh slate of instructors but just from
this example you can see that these are
experienced professionals who have been
using blockchain technology for for a
long time in the industry and they
actually do the live training sessions
and I am going to I am the program
director I have I have designed the
curriculum I uh also uh to deliver most
of the uh most of the um
the master classes and also uh time to
time uh change the curriculum to fit
with the current trends and and so on
and so forth so so my my role is uh more
as a program director uh uh and I
sometimes ask my colleagues also to do
the some of the master classes uh but
most of the thing is kind of directed by
myself
so what are the learner outcomes
so learner profiles from the
last I I guess about 24 24 months I'm
not exactly remembering exactly when we
started but about uh two years of uh
this thing uh we have been learning uh
running and I think by now more than uh
400 or so uh people have been trained
through this program
uh so uh business financial sector
Banking and Financial sector uh has the
highest number of participants from
uh distribution and service about 22
percent whereas manufacturing is 19 and
infrastructure and public sector is
about six percent each uh many of the
companies from which we get the Learners
are IBM Accenture uh TCS these are some
of the companies from which we get the
learners
so another poll that Stuart will learn
now
um
so uh this uh this is about are you
interested in in this program
uh
so I guess the maybe is missing but
that's okay you can yeah sorry about
that yeah
I did update the slide deck but uh
unfortunately I haven't earlier
and answers to this question is not
binding so uh you can answer what you
think right now you may change your mind
later but uh what is your uh you know
interesting and we'll close the poll in
10 seconds
oh so that's that's pretty uh High
um uh interest
I have to say
okay so that's good so uh um now coming
to the enrollment steps
so I think uh if you have any questions
you can ask
answer
ask at this email address
uh so you have to submit an application
applications will be reviewed by by the
team in at simply learned and then based
on the review application admission
decisions will be provided
uh I believe the cost is uh cost is
about uh you know 1.7 plus I think this
includes tax
and this is uh next class starts on
February 4th I believe that the cohort
start every month so so there at any
point there are multiple overlapping
codes one quote is in their first month
when the another court is in their
second month another was is in their
third month and so on
however uh you know if you are going to
do it uh it's better to do it as as soon
as you want to do it because uh
otherwise uh seats may be limited in
each part because of the Capstone
projects and so on we cannot have a very
large numbers uh supported
so now another poll
and so another poll I guess
uh Stuart will run this uh
so how soon do you want to uh enroll
and as Dr Shukla said
if this is something that's going to
improve your career in your life
it's usually better to start sooner than
later okay so um
so I guess
um some people want to start immediately
but uh more people want to start doing
in three months six months and
and maybe even letter yeah
if you add up the immediately and within
three months there's about half of the
respondents right to start in this
cohort of the one right after so right
right yeah so remember that uh once you
complete this program you become your
fundamentals become strong hopefully and
you become uh you know familiar with
Hands-On development of blockchain
applications uh you get something for
your resume in terms of your Capstone
project and and and uh and so on uh but
your learning starts
um lifelong right so it's not like
something that you just do it and then
you become the lifelong expert on this
because this technology is evolving
really fast and and therefore you have
to keep up with the uh what is going on
in the technology Evolution uh so
therefore uh that's why I was saying
that starting early is is a good idea
because there is lot more to learn and
technology is moving and you have more
uh if you can get your fundamentals
right and and properly done through this
course then you can actually then hone
your skills to do further development of
your skill set uh your your
understanding your uh expertise and
experience so you can get better and
better in your career if you're if this
is the career you want to choose
okay so now uh now we can
uh we can go a question and answer uh so
Stuart are you going to select some
questions for me or uh
yes I will and we have
quite a lot of questions so I've logged
in a few
logged in a few of them
um
so
Vishal asks uh
what percentage of the lectures are
conducted by IIT conference faculty and
how many from
simply learn
Ed
yeah so uh around 100 out of live
classes are conducted by chemical
industry book everyone there's a master
class that is conducted by the IIT
so duration of that master classes
yeah also the
again worth noting that the the
course content is overseen by IIT com
core there was a question about whether
this is whether it's possible to take
the course directly from IIT conport and
and the answer to that is that
you are essentially taking the course
directly from IIT com Port as we are the
official delivery partner and so
received your certificate from
IIT Concord and not simply
right so I I think that uh this is the
only way to take this class there is no
uh other uh version of this course which
is run by IIT kanpur alone uh simple
learn is the delivery partner so which
is this course and the reason is of
course that one is simply land provides
the platform and learning management
system uh the scheduling and the and the
enrollment can
all that stuff but other other than the
than that the the uh the industry
experts uh are are actually uh brought
in uh uh for delivering the content
because more than the professors they
are actually doing working in the
trenches and and developing uh
developing blockchain based applications
and and uh back end of blockchain and
and so on uh I know the instructors uh
and they are actually quite a bit uh
more uh practical experience than uh IIT
professors would be because professors
are more uh you know fundamentals and
and theory and and uh blockchain new
techniques for blockchain development
and so on uh which is uh more uh from
the backhand from the back end
you know support of the technology
Evolution rather than uh necessarily Dev
doing practical hands on all the time so
so it's not it's it's deliberately that
way that we uh course is delivered by
industry people than than IIT faculty
directly IIT faculty will give you
master classes where they will talk
about new things like how cryptocurrency
based blockchain foreign
uh we had a question about uh why
blockchain technology is looming so much
now why it's so popular and why it's
taking hold so well
uh Professor if you'd like to talk about
that yeah so blockchain technology uh is
actually there are several reasons uh
one area where blockchain technology is
uh quite being quite a bit making in
roads is uh payments uh space the
fintech what they call fintech and they
have this notion of decentralized
finance of D5
and the idea is that the payments in
today's world digital payments are
actually extremely expensive they uh
there are so many intermediaries when
you actually make a payment even if you
make a payment like say through UPI uh
it has to go through your uh payment uh
wallet provider then it has to go to
your uh you know uh the your UPI address
provider then it has to go to your bank
then it has to go to your uh other uh
the address provider of the recipient
then it has to go to the recipient's
bank so you see so many different
intermediaries are involved and that
means that this intermediaries uh not
only slow down the payment process but
also they actually create a lot of
friction uh in terms of not only time
but in terms of also money money because
it costs money to actually run all this
different systems to actually make a UPI
payment possible a lot of this payment
is now absorbed by npci but it will not
be always the case so similarly when you
pay by net banking or anything it's it's
a it's a lot of intermediaries
whereas blockchain is a decentralized
platform
which allows you to do the direct
sharing peer-to-peer sharing of
information
and that leads to reduction of
intermediaries reduction of this
friction which will not only make it
cost effective in the in the near future
for making digital payments but also
will make the other things like loan uh
approval and Loan disbursement process
and other processes uh faster and more
uh peer-to-peer and less intermediary
less friction and therefore uh it makes
it makes life a lot better and cheaper
uh as you know that Indian government
has already started a pilot for cbdc the
the
Central Bank digital currency that will
be a good example of contrast between
UPI and payment system that is friction
that has much less friction because it's
using something for decentralized Ledger
technology so uh so therefore the in the
payment space in the decentralized
finance space blockchain is making a lot
of inroads the other area where
blockchain is making a lot of inroads is
government services like government
provides a lot of services like aadhar
for example is a service that the
government provides to us for creating
our identity however in other the all
the data is is maintained by a authority
uidi authority and there is a lot of
mistrust about what they can do with by
my data can they leak out my data can
they sell my data can they do uh you
know can we turn off my identity and and
so on so this lack of trust in
government services can we uh cannot be
good for democracy cannot be good for
governance and therefore uh a a platform
which generates a trustworthy
interaction even though you do not cross
individual layers in the in the in the
ecosystem that's what blockchain
technology provides you that that
getting trust out of a trustless
environment so that's where he
governance uh the land record registry
and so on the transparency the
immutability of the data Etc will
provide you with the trust that of the
public in the e-governance solutions so
uh similarly for uh identity Solutions
uh for example uh it's a lot more
frictionless than than having to do a
kyc through through your fingerprint and
so on if we can have identity on the
blockchain so these are reasons why
blockchain technology is making a lot of
star and of course there are uh there is
always a
um you know wasted interest of the
current Marketplace who may not
necessarily accept the new technology to
replace the old technology so there is
always a friction and and that friction
in that friction sometimes you know we
may see that there is a resistance and
there is a there is a reluctance by many
organizations to actually embrace
blockchain but this is changing more and
more and and we we are hoping that this
is this will change eventually like uh
the internet and and things like that
when it first came people didn't
understand how to use it and what is the
use for uh that and all that stuff but
as soon as uh World Wide Web came and
and uh and the emails
worldwide web based emails like Hotmail
and and Google mail and Yahoo mail Etc
came things started catching up very
very fast so that's what is happening
with the blockchain technology
we have a couple of questions from
people who work in in Finance and
Accounting
um
one person who asks who says they have
15 years of work in credit risk and
digital lending
um one who says their chartered
accountant
um what are some of the the ways that
blockchain will affect those areas and
is
is it valuable for them to to know about
technology
all right so uh
[Music]
uh I personally do not know
um what Chartered Accountants do I guess
they do accounting uh and and also
certify certify statements of accounts
of organizations and institutes uh so I
think that there is a lot of data that
that they have to collect and and they
have to they have to make sure that the
uh expenses and and earnings Etc are uh
and taxes are in line with the
regulations and laws and all that stuff
and uh there is a possibility that this
data that we are provided by the
organization may not be uh truthful
so so there there because there is a
lack of transparency uh and and they are
dependent on the data provided to them
to create the statements of accounts and
so on so I I assume that if you if you
could create a system in which every
time an expense is incurred and earning
is incurred and and then and the uh tax
is being paid Etc all that data is uh in
a trans is transparent uh to at least uh
to to the chartered accountant or to the
uh compliance people then and which is
imputable which cannot be changed and
therefore uh the uh the provenance of
the data the uh the proof of
non-manipulation of the data Etc could
actually help them to feel uh better in
certifying them but this is totally a
speculative answer because I really do
not know what the Chartered Accountants
do uh in terms of Financial Risk Etc
also the same same kind of things like
transparency and Trust uh um among the
parties contracts that are that are uh
you know algorithmically enforced rather
than you know based on best uh uh you
know the Goodwill of the players uh
might be actually a better uh solution
uh but these are all speculative answers
that I can think of
okay thank you um we had a couple of
questions about whether a programming
background is required or what
programming language would be involved
in
blockchain technology can you comment on
that
yeah so uh yeah so I usually suggest
that a programming experience or
programming background would be the best
to take make the best uh of course as I
said that you could become you can take
the course
and you have to have an attitude that I
will learn things uh avoiding
programming but I will I will then try
to understand the concepts the
architecture the why the blockchain is
why the blockchain is useful where it is
useful I will learn how the smart
contracts uh why the smart contracts are
important and what they actually provide
us which I cannot get from regular
programs if you if you want to learn in
in those terms then you don't need
programming background but you will not
become a blockchain developer for
example or application developer or
front-end developer for blockchain
Solutions you will be more like more on
the side of the architecture for the
project management and so on
if you are if you are if you want to
become if you want to develop Solutions
uh through blockchain applications if
you want to develop blockchain
based solutions to
payments problems or or financial
problems or for uh e-governance problems
or you know GST Implement GST on on
blockchain Etc then of course you have
to know programming and uh I guess uh in
the slides we have said that Java would
be probably the best thing because uh in
hyper Ledger we can write smart
contracts in Java but that doesn't mean
that you have to know Java any
programming language if you know then
usually you can learn the other ones so
for example when you learn about
ethereum and smart contracts in ethereum
you will probably learn about solidity
but solidity is different from java and
uh
um but but it's a programming language
so if you knew any other programming
language you will get get to learn that
solidity of course uh you don't become
uh a fluent qualitative programmer uh or
fluent uh you know go go Lang programmer
Etc uh by taking a course you have to
practice them you have to go and find
other resources where they actually go
step by step programming here the focus
will be on move on blockchain technology
and and applications blockchain
fundamentals concepts of blockchain why
they work and how they work and and so
on so to actually become blockchain
developer Beyond this course also you
have to do your own studies to learn
either go and if you are doing chain
code in Poland or uh you have to do a
solidity if you are going to develop
smart contracts and applications
uh in in ethereum and so on so forth so
but yeah I mean uh depending on what
your goal is uh sometimes we find people
they get very worked up because
they don't know programming and they're
in the middle of the course and their
classmates are writing smart contracts
and so on and they are not able to write
uh in that case I would suggest that you
have to have the attitude adjustment
that what is it that you are trying to
get out of the course if you are trying
to get out of the course uh that I want
to become I want to get get to the point
where I can
um you know
successively learn more about say
solidity or something and develop the
apps or uh distributed decentralized
apps Etc then uh of course if you don't
know programming you should be worked up
but if you want to become a blockchain
solution architect or blockchain project
manager or something you do not have to
uh you you should try it will see what
what what is being taught in terms of
smart contract programming and so on but
you you should not get a very worked up
if you cannot always go through that so
so it depends on your attitude and what
you want to get out of this course
thank you
um I do have a comment from pranab who
says I've already enrolled in the course
almost toward the end of it it's a good
one and I joined to listen to Dr
shirtless uh there you go that's uh
shout out from for knob and and then the
last questions I want to take for uh my
aunt um to talk about uh
um some people have asked whether
there's job assistance and what the job
prospects are for program graduates and
that type of thing so what information
do you have in mind for that
so uh you have a few questions on jobs
so this program in this program it's not
a job guarantee program but we do
provide a job assistant now about that
job assistance needed that for the
skills we provide a statements Pro
membership of I am Job supported we do
conduct uh resume building in career
main transition I think that are
conducted by Amazon jobs itself
uh and there are interview session that
are conducted
so for this program we do provide job
assistant but it's not a job guarantee
the resume building and the interview
prep are extremely valuable because
in the modern world your resume doesn't
go in front of a human being until it
passes through a
automated tracking system and an AI bot
so um having help from a professional
who can help you craft your resume so
that the AI will recognize how it fits
with the job description and so the
resume is still attractive when it lands
in front of a human being that's a a
very valuable uh
skill set to help you with as well as
interview preparation that lets you
prepare for both the technical
interviews about your blockchain skills
but also the soft skills and managerial
and
interviews that talk about team
playing and teamwork and
your other aspects of being a good
employee so those are really valuable
and as mine said they extend for six
months after you get the certificate you
have access to those services so
um with that we're at time and um
so I would like to just run the last
poll if you show that slide Professor
very last one
and um this is just for the people who
are interested in enrolling
um do you
need further assistance from us
questions or
advice on how to get the enrollment
process going
and we'll leave this open for about a
minute
and the numbers stop changing so I'm
going to
show the result here
50 50.
um so
again I have put into the chat but I
will also put in again
the
uh email address ask us simplylearn.net
so that it's uh at your fingertips
and
um
do want to mention that um
Professor Scrolls back
that concludes the
webinar we will be sending out an email
with a
link to this recording if you want to
review that some people had asked about
a proof of attendance certificate we
don't usually uh
issue those for these types of webinars
but
we do that for our
other types of career and
technology webinars so
hopefully
you'll get value from the recording but
we ask you to contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
get any final questions answered or to
get the enrollment process started
I want to thank Mayan for being here I
want to thank Dr Shukla
for being so generous with his time and
his knowledge today
and I want to thank everybody who joined
us for the webinar
so with that
um
have a great evening and that concludes
our webinar for tonight
thank you Stuart thank you Mayan and
have a good day evening whatever is in
store for you
all right goodbye doll
[Music]